howdy guys we are back for episode two
um Von cash it was uh week four
um and I want to give a special shout
out to my guy Trey white man he tore his
Achilles
um during the game
um it was just uh you know he was just
running behind Tyreek Hill and he just
stepped down and he tore his Achilles
man it's a tough injury and he just uh
you know got back from uh his ACL on
last year so it's been a cuff it's been
a tough couple of years for Trey white
man I just wanted to give him a special
shout out at the beginning of this
Vaughn cast because I know personally
how hard it is to to overcome these
injuries man and he'll be good man I
just want to send him some love and I
think we should all send him some love
man so I appreciate you uh T white and I
see you I see you in a little bit
um
as we get uh as we get started man
um Sunday was a crazy uh win for my team
they absolutely beat the brakes off of
the Miami Dolphins they did not me it
went crazy we got to see these guys
again so I don't want to fire anybody
else but it just it just uh it just is
what it is man they went crazy man my
team went crazy obviously I didn't play
you know um in that game but they just
you know went crazy on the Denver
Broncos the week before they put a 70
ball on shot and Payton and all of those
guys man and you know coming to this
game it was a it was a lot of hype um
about the Miami Dolphins rightfully so
because they have a really good team
but uh my team just played really really
good and I talked to Bradley Chubb
before the game like you know because
Bradley chill was my guy and I had
reached out to chub and I was like hey
man we about to beat the brakes off of
y'all and he was like yeah man you know
we got a good team because obviously I
wasn't playing like when you playing in
games you obviously don't you know talk
how I'm talking but I wasn't playing so
I can talk you know my team up all I
want
and I was telling him like Hey man
anybody beat the brakes off of y'all he
was like yeah we're gonna see you man we
got a good team too
and I talked to him about the Denver
game because we were both in Denver as
well we talked about the Denver Broncos
and how they're struggling and you know
how was the game playing in the game we
asked for 70 points or and whatnot so
talking to Bradley children I said hey
man we're gonna be the brakes off y'all
and then actually after we actually did
it I saw him after the game and I was
like Hey chill we beat the brakes off of
y'all he just busted out laughing man so
he was a it was a little chuckle there
being chub had man but we'll see those
guys again man and you know it'll be uh
sooner than we know man see those guys
at the end of the season man and Tool
has been playing out of his mind Tyreek
Hill's been playing out of his mom so
they got a lot more time to really you
know get back together and they got some
big big games coming up and we'll see
those guys in the season but I think
that says what this says about our
defense you know especially you know
with me not playing is that we have a
really really solid defense it's not
just the Josh Allen and the offense it's
not just the it's just not the Josh
Allen Show it's um we have a really
really solid team you know our special
teams played out of their mind as well
um and our defense played out of their
mind for it for two weeks in a row so I
really I really think that that uh
proves the people that we have a solid
team in general not just quarterback not
just receivers
um not just defensive line um we have a
really really solid team and that's what
you need to to have to get to the big
ship and ultimately win it
um the stadium was insane
the stadium was insane man like it was
uh it was typical Buffalo Bills
um it was it was a typical Buffalo Bill
Sunday
um I say that and you know we were
scoring a lot of touchdowns everybody
was having fun man even Diggs was having
so much fun with the fans he you know
had beers and he went stole he went and
stole cold uh Stefan Diggs you know
during the game and I thought that was
super cool I thought that was super cool
man and the energy on the sideline we're
big on energy on the sideline man we
always like to um you know have
especially the people that's not playing
like the coaches and the walk and the
and the practice squad guys we want
those guys to be into the game
so every single player you can see all
those guys getting hype off of every
single play Man and the the energy was
was insane
um Josh Allen and Stefan Diggs had a
huge game you know Josh Allen was the
second player in NFL history with three
with 300 yards passing two touchdown Pat
I mean four touchdown passes and one
rushing touchdown and a one
five eight point three
QB rating in a single game that was a
whole lot to say he's a second player in
NFL history with 300 yards passing four
touchdown passes one Russian tech one
Russian Pat one Russian touchdown and
158.3 uh quarterback rating in a single
game he absolutely went crazy
he um has more touchdowns than
incompletions in that game it was insane
man and Steph went crazy too
um he had 120 yards receiving with three
touchdowns and like I said before man he
went Stone Cold Stefan Diggs he had two
beers and like he hit him together man
and that's that's how you know man like
we were they we're going super crazy man
and I just feel like you know that's
just that's what we're um that's the
team that we're supposed to be
um
I think when we play to the best of our
ability that's us
um and I think our our mindset going
into that week is something that we can
replicate I don't think that was just a
a
um
a one-game wonder I think we really
focused on our mental toughness and I
think we've really focused on the
process and how do we get to games like
that so we can continue to replicate
that
um and that's that's what I saw for my
team man I saw a resilient team a humble
team you know I I can sit here and talk
about those guys but you know we have a
huge um a hugely humble team in there um
everybody's all about wins everybody's
so selfless
um with each other they want the best
out of out of the guy next to them man
and you know I think we can continue to
replicate that as long as we continue to
reset and just keep keep going crazy man
um with that performance Josh Allen
became the front runner for MVP he's
always been my front runner he's always
been the front runner in my eyes for the
MVP
but um you know I I feel like Josh has
uh continue to develop he he's continued
to develop each and every game each and
every play after that first game you
know the first game he had four
um
he had four turnovers just with himself
he threw three interceptions and he had
a fumble and he lost it fumble so he had
four um turnovers within just by himself
and I think he's he's taking that
performance and he's just
he just said that as as the floor for
him he's put it behind him and he's just
grinded and he just continues to develop
each and every play Not Just game each
and every play he gets better and better
and better I think our offensive line is
continue to get better and better and
better and everybody around you know our
offensive line and Josh has continued to
get better and better and better so it's
been it's been amazing to see Josh
become the official MVP MVP front-runner
because he's always been my favorite if
you ask me
um I think what he has to do to keep the
momentum going is just continue to reset
you know games are going to be different
teams are going to be different defenses
are going to be different um stadiums
and circumstances are going to continue
to be different but if he can just
continue to reset and take it truly One
play at a time I don't think it's
nothing stopping Josh Allen he has all
the tools in the toolbox
um he can make every throw he can run
the ball
um he can do everything that that it
takes to be a
MVP quarterback I think it's just all on
Josh and that is a great place to be if
you ask me
um let's look at some other contenders
that have a chance to win MVP um 201 is
number one you know before this week
um but you know the defense our defense
went crazy and you know Buffalo Bills
won the game so that moves Josh number
one Patrick Mahomes will always be in
the MVP race and so will Jalen hurts
um and so will Lamar Jackson Justin
Herbert is good to see on here too I
mean he's a he is a really good
quarterback I'm gonna be it'll be dope
to see Christian McCaffrey win MVP as
well because I don't think there has
been
um a MVP
um running back since Adrian Peterson
and we get we'll get to that in a little
bit Brock Purdy would be a great one to
see too but I don't think
any of them would be as good to see for
me in my eyes than Josh Allen you know I
really uh wanted for Josh she's done so
much man I'm sure everybody on this list
they feel like they deserve it and all
the fans are these guys on this list
they feel like they deserve it but I'm
in a room with Josh Allen each and every
day and I I truly know that he deserves
it man it'd be great for the Buffalo
Bills to see that happen you know Josh
Allen wins the MVP that means we're
having we have a really good team and at
the end of the season you know things
are looking pretty good for us so I
would love to to see Josh Allen win the
Super Bowl MVP Micah Hyde also balled
out as well you know he's had
back-to-back weeks with an interception
um this last game he had five tackles in
one interception you know he had a a
really good interception in the game
today
um that came from pressure you know we
just talked about this uh yesterday in
the meeting room and he should have
stayed down the line he should have said
he should have stayed to that that close
hash that he had right down the sideline
maybe he would have scored but I think
it's just the Iowa Hawkeye in him and he
just he don't wants to run around and
see if he can go against the grain and
make it happen but you know to see
Michael High come back and have the
success that he's having especially
after you know getting injured last
season and being out for the whole
season and you see him come back and
make plays man that is super cool man
shout out to my guy my god
um you know the wind and my God wasn't
the only big news for Buffalo Bills
Demar Hamlin
made his NFL return
um and no none of this stuff was
surprising to me because I see him
practice each and every day and I saw
him practicing training camp so I'm
playing the preseason so I knew he was
ready
um but Jordan poyer being down he was
officially up you know this uh weekend
is it's really really cool and really
really dope to see him make that whole
360 return to itself again man and I'm
so happy for tomorrow man and I want to
wish him continued success you know he
also talked to the Press you know after
um the game and you know let's go to it
and check him out let's see what he said
after the game
I felt amazing you know the energy from
the fans
um was amazing you know but just being
able to be out there with my teammates
you know have my family in the stands
play again with you know
everybody on the team that just gives me
confidence just feeds me like positive
energy positive everything all week long
and just to get out there and play with
everybody again felt amazing
man it's dope man it's dope man like I
said I really wasn't surprised man
because I'm at practice with this guy
each and every day and I know he's been
ready so it's a
I'm neither surprised or satisfied with
uh tomorrow man I know that he has a
whole lot left in the tank man and he
contribute to this team in so many
different ways man so I'm neither
surprised or satisfied with Demar Hamlin
and his return to the NFL
um
this game was circled on our schedule
you know for our defense we knew it was
going to be a tough game winning some
Miami Dolphins
um when I look at the remaining schedule
some of the building some of the biggest
challenges some of the biggest
challenges for our defense
um would have to be
I mean you know you want to stay you
know you want to stay you know week to
week of course you know you we want to
stay week to week and we have a huge
challenge with the uh Jacksonville
Jaguars in London this week but just
looking down the schedule which coach
probably wouldn't advise me to do but I
do this for the Von cast for you guys
man and when I look at the schedule
I see
the Eagles the Chiefs the Cowboys
and the Chargers
all back to back to back to back
in November December
and um those are going to be tough games
I mean you got Jalen Harris Patrick
homes Dak Prescott and Justin Herbert
man and we just seen Khalil Mack go
crazy and all those things but I talked
I talked I talk about those guys later
in the um I talk about that guy later in
the show
but all of those teams would be
um tough for us and I think you know um
what we have to do to keep playing to
the same level that we've played at this
last past week is just to continue to
reset and to continue to take it one
week at a time
um that's all you can do International
Football League
um because you see each and every week a
team wins that shouldn't win and you see
a team lose that shouldn't lose so you
gotta always take it week to week man
and football is just one of those
rah-rah Sports and I know that we'll be
able to if we continue if we can
continue to reset
um continue to let the pressure come
from within because when you're your
biggest critic you're not listening to
anything that's happening on the outside
um two weeks ago they were talking about
the Washington commanders team and how
good their defensive line was and they
didn't say anything about the Buffalo
Bills defensive line so if you listen to
the outside world you know things change
sometimes they'll be with you sometimes
they'll begin be against you
I feel like we have to continue to be
our biggest critic the pressure has to
continue to come from inward not from
without I mean from the outside world
and I feel like you know we can be able
to replicate this success and
you know all of these teams are going to
be tough teams to beat but our defense
if we can just continue to keep the main
thing the main thing and it's turnovers
playing as a team uh continue to make
the the Russian coverage go together I
feel like we continue to have success
um
and if we get me back I will be able to
contribute to this defense as well I'm
losing Trey white was a huge blow for us
um hopefully I can feel some of it I
won't be able to feel it as much as you
know having Trey white there man there's
a tough you know break for Trey white
man but I'll be able to come back man
it's been since Thanksgiving since I've
put on football pads and practiced and
did any of these things so I'll be able
to practice tomorrow for the first time
super excited to get back out there with
those guys I've been leading from you
know the film room and leading from the
sidelines for so long man and
um not like I'm complaining that's just
what God had put on the table for me so
I had to take advantage of it I think
one of the biggest
um
one of the biggest things that happened
for me with this team is being able to
be a team captain from the sideline um
being able to be a team captain I'm not
even playing so that was one of the most
um
that was one of the most enjoyable
moments of this this season for me is
being able to be a team captain I'm not
even practicing I'm not even playing
with the guys so these are the guys that
voted for me and I didn't vote for
myself now in one vote I never do that I
feel like that's so lame when I get a
sheet and I have the ability to vote for
myself and I do I just feel like it's
not
you know it's not genuine because if you
if you actually get this like man
they're my one vote matter so never
never vote for myself voted for
everybody else and to be able to get the
ballot back and I was a team captain was
was super cool and especially I haven't
been practicing or I haven't played
since Thanksgiving so the rehab process
was was super um I want to say tough but
it it really wasn't
because I've been through it before
obviously you know going through ACL
rehab is is no walking apart
um but I just think the perspective that
I have on it
um and really my enjoyment of the game
and I really enjoy being a Buffalo Bill
I really didn't
let it
um down me I really didn't let it you
know
you know kill my mood or kill my vibe
and you know um and this year 13 for me
like I'm on my third contract I got two
beautiful boys like what I look like
walking around the facility depressed
because I you know I told my ACL like
obviously it's tough and obviously I
want to be back on the football field
but you know this it happened and I
can't look back so I continue to stay
positive
um I continue to uplift my teammates and
I can and I tried to find other ways to
really be involved and really help out
with my teammates and I think that's
what helped me from being like so down
on the floors I just found other ways to
contribute and that really just took my
mind off of what was happening with me
um and you know to have the opportunity
to come back because it's still not
promised that I play in this game
I want to play in this game I got to
practice tomorrow
and I only get one padded practice so
obviously I go out there and I look
amazing with this padded practice
because the difference is like in
training camp you get multiple padded
practices to kind of like
figure your game out I just get one
padded practice tomorrow and then we
have a sales practice on Thursday and
then we fly to London on Thursday night
so I really don't I really don't have
all the time in the world to like figure
out I'll get one padded practice so
hopefully I look amazing tomorrow I feel
really strongly that I will that's just
how I think I feel like I will
be amazing tomorrow and everybody will
give me the green light to go play the
game
um and I feel like the fans
I don't know if the fans can expect to
see me yet but if I was a bad man I
would say yeah you can expect to see Von
Miller in London this is my first time
playing in London and you know who knows
how many chances I get to play in London
so I want this to happen I'm pushing
forward to happen
um I think I think you can go ahead and
and really check that box and you guys
will see me playing in London
um
and uh it's been a lot of guys that's
been going off it's it's been a lot of
guys that's been going off Khalil Mack
had six sacks
um I don't want to I want to get back in
that conversation you know I wanna I
wanna I wanna fight for that top spot
um it's been a lot of guys that's been
going off like Khalil Mack
um miles Garrett
um TJ wad
um Leonard Floyd he's been having a
great year
um
Greg Russo has been having a great year
Ed Oliver these are all guys that I see
each and every day my bad
um Michael Parsons has been going crazy
um and these are some of the guys that I
that I that I respect around the league
and I respect those their game so I got
a lot of catching up to do but I feel
strongly
um that I'll be able to to get back in
the mix of things really really quick
um and we got some we got some we got
some questions in the chat
let me see uh Carlton Ross says go bills
said the team is about to get a even
bigger boost when 40 comes back yes I
hope so
uh Conor McKenna
says Von it's gonna be a problem when
you get back out there that is true that
is true I really hope so
um kpad 12 says are the Lions the real
deal yes they are the they are the real
deal did you not see the first game of
the season
when they beat Patrick Mahomes in the
Kansas City Chiefs of course they are
the real deal
um
I think it's
Cod Esther's uh code dusters I'm not
sure these usernames are crazy but he
says was the was the Miami game
really loud as it sounds
and every and everybody said it was yes
it was it was insane and um it felt like
a college game you know I went to Texas
A M and I played a lot of a lot of love
games and this was this one was really
loud
um ADI Mark says did you watch The Toy
Story broadcast with your voice no I
didn't I did not um
I was I had to be at the stadium at 11
A.M so I didn't get a chance to but I
thought it was super cool man the game
was played on carpet the game was played
on Harvey Med and they was able to
recreate it and and uh and have it it
just looked amazing man I I watched it
though I watched it
I watched a little bit of it but I just
thought it was super cool and especially
for the NFL to be able to create a
product that's
that's um marketable to the younger
audience because the younger audience is
the future of our league so I thought
that was super cool that they're
thinking about everybody and they're
being able to include the young kids the
big kids like myself and everybody that
loves football
um it was a fun week around the league
um I can't talk week four without giving
my former team the Denver Broncos a huge
shout out and a huge comeback win
against the Bears it
was looking pretty shaky at first I'm
not gonna
um
I I was looking at the screen and uh I
saw it I think it was like three to 21
or I think it was like
yeah I think it was three to twenty one
and I was like oh man it's happening
again man like the bear is about to
score 50 points on the Denver Broncos
because we know the week before 70
points like was a tough week and um
you know for them to be able to come
back and have a 21 Point 21 Point
comeback time for the second largest
comeback on the road in team history
yeah it has to be because we had a we
had a huge win we had a huge comeback
win
um my uh Monday night football versus
Philip Rivers I think it was 21 points
too
um against Philip Rivers on Monday Night
Football
I think they will have 21-0 at the half
and we able to come back and win that
game 28-0 but that's in the past this is
about the present this is about the
president and this team really really
needed that that win
um because last week it was it was
looking bad in the beginning of the
other of the game it got crazy too but
that just shows you how resilient this
uh Broncos team in it is and how
resilient my little brothers are man
Sean Payton
he uh cut off his sleeves uh mid game
and then then the team scored 24
unanswered points so maybe it was up his
sleeves you know maybe maybe the magic
baby to help he needed it it was just
that he had something up his sleeves for
real
you ever had something up his sleeves
for real man
and they cut him off man and he went
crazy I'm not sure what was the big deal
about you know the cups maybe he's not a
cuff guy I
maybe he's not a cuff guy man because he
cut the Cuffs off man look at him he got
a little area in there
he got his hands on his knees man he was
ready to go there
um but I think this win I think this win
tells people that the Broncos are
resilient I think this win tells
um Broncos country that they are better
than
um they're 20 to 70 score that they had
the week before
I think this tells you know Broncos
country and the AFC West that they have
what it takes to be competitive Russell
Wilson went crazy and not only did he go
crazy this game but he's actually been
crazy he's actually been going crazy all
season long quietly
he's actually been going crazy all
season long and this is what I've said
all along about Russell Wilson I said it
all along that this year was going to be
way better than the year before man and
Russell Wilson is going crazy man I
think his uh his passing rating was was
higher than Josh Allen's passion rate in
this last week man and you know that
just shows like man Russ is cooking I'm
excited for Russ man and you know they
they definitely have what it takes
um
now the Bears are 0-4 now the Bears are
0-4 and the Broncos are one and three so
um I think the Bears in a in a little
tougher spot
um
You Know It's just tough to see a team
struggle in Pro Sports man like it's
tough to see like you know teams like go
0 and 4 because I know so many people
put their their all into this game so
many people want to see their pro team
be successful and you know when you see
it man it's just it's tough man I've
been that team before you know we've at
the Denver Broncos we've been we've had
years where we struggled just like them
man and what I would say to those guys
man is you just gotta keep pushing man
and
you gotta always keep the main thing the
main thing I know these things are
cliche but when you are a pro athlete
it's not like you can leave when you
want to leave this is this is where you
are and you just got to continue to to
do your job and then do more
because the do-more part is
is the tricky thing because doing your
job that's what you have to do to be a
successful player in this league but the
do-more part is what you need to change
your team from a loser team to a winning
team so you have to do your job that's
just a Baseline and then you have to do
more I know it sounds cliche but that is
that is the truth man you know I want to
continue to take a second
to uh put my GM hat on for you guys
because we have some teams that might
need it right now
if I were at the Broncos GM
after that being after that big comeback
win I would um
I would continue to feel the fire
um I will continue to because this game
is is really 70 confidence because
everybody out there can play ball
so after we get a big win like that
especially a comeback win like if they
just killed him from the beginning to
the end like that's what they're
supposed to do
but you know come back win shows that
they were just you know chilling at
first and then they just turned it on so
I will continue to fuel the fire I will
continue to tell those guys hey man we
got a franchise quarterback we got a
quarterback that's been to the Super
Bowl and can win it hey we got franchise
receivers and we got a franchise defense
our offensive line is set we gotta uh we
gotta we got a Super Bowl winning head
coach and quarterback we know what it
takes to get there
we just gotta continue to to reset and
take it one week at a time
um I think they had the Chiefs this week
this is gonna be a good one because if
they can they can win this game versus
the Chiefs not only does that help the
Buffalo Bills but then that helps the
different because they well that helps
you during Broncos as well so
I would say hey man like I would use
that I would ride these guys up to pump
them up a little bit so we can play to
the best of our ability versus the
Chiefs because they have the receivers
to do it
Courtney Sutton Jerry Judy can't nobody
guard these guys they got a solid
offensive line from the inside out from
a glitchy Gary Bowles
to my guys on the inside from uh from
from my uh my uh from Quentin and all
the other guys that got in there they
have a solid they have a solid offensive
line they have a solid defensive line
too
um Coupe that's my guy played with Coop
Randy Randy Gregory all these guys can
can play Man Jonathan Cooper Randy
Gregory
um they're solid on the inside as well
they have a really good defense line
they have DBS they have the best
cornerback in the NFL with Patrick
certain they got guys that can match up
against these guys so I would just
continue to fuel the fire man I would
say hey man we got what it takes to win
these games we we've seen what what it
what happens when we don't play our best
you know uh via the Miami Dolphins and
we've seen what happens when we do play
our best via the Chicago Bears and them
being able to come back and score 24 and
answer points so they have what it takes
man they just gotta reset and just go
out there and do it man and I'm sure
Sean Payton have those guys going man
Sean Payton will have those guys going
man
um the adjustments I would make to
tearing the patriots the patriots season
around um
I would bring Tom Brady back
I will bring Tommy I'll try to break Tom
Brady back
I played in the in the I played during
the Patriots uh Championship era
um when they had Tom Brady and man it
was crazy man it just felt like
everything that they did was insane
um when they had Gronkowski and you know
they had uh uh Edelman like oh my God it
just felt like everything that they did
just made it and their defense was Stout
as well man like it just felt like
everything they did they were able to
have success
um
and then I would I would just have a sit
down with Max Jones and I'm sure they
they've done this before
but I would just let Mac Jones know that
he has what it takes to be successful
you know in this league like you know
obviously obviously you know um being
benched and bringing zap in you know
that was uh that was tough but I'm sure
he'd be starting this week man because
he has what it takes he had three
turnovers in the first half and I
watched that Cowboys Patriots games man
in the first game and it was tough man
it was really really tough so
he has what it takes that's just not him
and you can't win games when your
quarterback is responsible for three
turnovers I'll tell you that ourselves
we had Josh Allen
he was responsible for four turnovers
and we didn't win that game we had a
chance but it just makes it tough like
when your quarterbacks turn the ball
over like that
um this was Bill Belichick's worst loss
and 29 Seasons as a head coach
will he stick it out or retire I think
he sticks it out like
you know when when you're when you're um
when you're a big time coach like coach
Belichick man and he's the GM like he
he's gonna be all right man like he's
gonna be all right man you got to get
Mac Jones going or you can trade for
Kirk Cousins
you could you can trade for Kirk Cousins
right now I'm sure uh I'm sure that
Minnesota the Minnesota Vikings they're
looking for a Suitor for Kirk Cousins
right now and they might be that might
be
um the place to go for you know the
Patriots I'm that's that's if they're if
they truly think that the Mac Jones
um experiment is not gonna work
obviously I believe in Mac Jones
but if they truly believe Mac Jones is
not gonna work then go get Kirk Cousins
go get Coke curtains and let's let's
write the ship cousins is a is a proven
quarterback you got Juju you got um
you got Zeke
um the offensive line is is one of the
best offensive lines in the league like
if you if you believe in the trade trade
uh Matt Jones for Kirk Cousins player
for player I'm sure I'm sure both teams
will be okay with that
because it's a lot of cap that they got
to bring in for Kirk Cousins he is paid
as well and you know that's what I would
do if I if I had my GM hat on
um if I had
as a GM if my franchise QB was was
struggling
um I would
sit him down and have a talk with them I
I think you start there first
um if you look at the Bengals you know
you got Joe Barrel the highest paid
player in NFL history you know and he's
having a rush start he's having a rough
start
um you just gotta sit down and talk to
him and Joe Barrel like you know he's uh
he's not fully healthy right now he's
he's not he's not fully healthy right
now he's still he's
he's uh you know trying to fight through
injuring so maybe we set him down maybe
we get him fully healthy before you know
we hurt him even more like maybe that's
you know maybe that's something that we
look at maybe we sit you know um
um Joe Barrow down for a little bit man
and then whenever he gets back healthy
we bring it back up
um Daniel Jones struggled against the
Seahawks
um
Daniel Jones like that's I feel like
that's different that's that's different
because
Daniel Jones
um
he doesn't first of all their left
tackle he didn't play he didn't have the
type of protection that you know that
Joe Barrel has
um
and then secondly
Daniel Jones is different because
Seattle Seahawks have a really good rush
they they really do and Geno Smith
played well in that game as well so
I think with all these guys before you
talk about trading and getting rid of
these guys you can you sit down and talk
to these guys and that that doesn't work
if that doesn't work you know via Daniel
Jones and you got to explore other
options
um
I would like to
take a second and Shout out any swifties
that's tuning in to the fun cast right
now
um
this is uh this is this is super cool
welcome to the NFL family
you know I I really appreciate you guys
um you know Travis is my guy man and you
know to see the the Taylor and Travis uh
a couple you know uh heating up man it's
it's exciting and it's dope you know
Travis is a super cool guy man and that
this is a a really really cool couple uh
and he had a crazy dream box right here
this is a dream box man like he had Hugh
Jackman not you but
Taylor Swift had a huge Eggman in there
Ryan Reynolds uh Blake Lively it was it
was insane man like and I would think
about like my DreamBox who would I have
in my DreamBox to come watch me
um
I think Lil Wayne will have to be in
there
um
I think Denzel Washington you know I'm
just bouncing around now I don't want it
to all be you know artists
um I think Elon Musk that would be super
cool to have Elon Musk come uh
come come to my game to watch me play
and I think uh President Obama
that'll be cool man if I had all of
those guys come in to watch my game that
would be insane man that would be a
dream you know a celebrity box to have
in my game to come watch me
um
Chet who do you think would be in your
in your celebrity box to come watch you
we haven't got today yet no we don't
have guys asking about
tonight we're gonna have guys with that
who who are they having their celebrity
box but we do have Nicholas
the Pota in here and he says
we miss you on the line brother
hope you can make it back to London all
right well you know I'll give you a
little you know inside scoop 90 I'm 90
sure that I'd be there in London I'll be
ready to play
um we got I Wilson
he said inject a Von Miller sack into my
veins I'm hoping to inject a whole lot
of formula sacks into your veins this
weekend
um we got H2 he said GM Vaughn any
interest in coaching after you're done
no way no way no how
um I sit in there every single day and
coaches they have I have so much respect
for coaches all across the world not
just football coaches but dance coaches
golf coaches like all type of coaches
all across the world mental coaches like
I just have so much respect for coaches
all across the world man that is a a
tough job and I just don't see Von doing
that I'd rather be able to go in there
and um find the talent I'd rather
um
I'd rather be um I'd rather evaluate the
talent for my coaches to go out there
and Coach them up
um he says uh
GM Vaughn what would you do with
Tennessee well Tennessee just had a huge
win against
uh Joe Barrow and uh and the Cincinnati
Bengals I think it was their first win
of the season
but they got Derek Henry they got they
got a dream they got a dream team
already they got Derrick Henry they got
Ryan Tannehill offensive line and stack
and they got Hopkins and her defense is
good and their coach by Mike Vapor man
like they already have a huge team it's
it's it's it's really striking to see
the the Tennessee Titans you know
struggling right now
um but let's talk about some guys who
are bawling right now CJ shirelle he's
been on the show before
CJ shroud is making a name for himself
in his first four games he is 94 for
151 passes he has six touchdowns and he
has 1212 yards and zero interceptions
like I told y'all man CJ Stroud is is
the god man he's looking good man CJ
shroud his last game in college I think
if versus Georgia he showed everybody
that he could play in the league it
shows everybody that he has what it
takes and he's doing it now in the
league man like shout out to CJ shroud
man he's going crazy
um she CJ shroud is is key for turning
this Texans team around it all starts
with the quarterback we all know that we
all know that's the quickest way to turn
your your team around and they have a
franchise quarterback and CJ shroud and
um
how far do I see him carrying a team
hopefully to the playoffs
the way he looking now man the sky is
the limit for this team the sky's the
limit for this team man and I'm excited
for CJ shroud in the in the in the
Houston Texans for sure
Khalil Mack made the Raiders wish they
never traded him he has six sacks versus
the Chargers and a 24-17 win
over the Raiders on Sunday six acts is
crazy
but I've seen the guy have five sacks in
the game before he had five sets in one
half so six sex throughout the game is
you know it's something that I I mean
I've seen it before and you know Saks
coming bunches he went into the game
with no sacks and he left the game with
six sacks so past sources we always like
to say sacks coming bunches and they
really do man Khalil Mack is going crazy
man and he's always going crazy I
remember when he was uh First Team all
pro as a linebacker and the defensive
lineman I remember when he won Defensive
Player of the Year over me
I think it was by one vote
he won over me
um so I am very familiar with uh with
Khalil Mack and all of all the Hall of
Fame talk that I get I think Khalil Max
should rightfully get the same Hall of
Fame talk about him and his career man
because he's done everything in the sun
man he is truly a a beast man and I have
nothing but respect for Khalil Mack he's
been to the pastor or something he's
contributed to the password summited in
so many different ways man
um
I love Khalil man I can't talk about you
know Khalil Mack um enough man
um Matt came ready to play and so did
the entire charger sideline after this
hit
um Justin Herbert was late hit on the on
the sideline and
the whole team came to his defense man
the whole team came to Memphis that's
the oh the Mac I mean my guy Shook at
the top for a second but his whole team
his whole team came his whole team came
to his his defense man look at that
there you go right there he's trying to
get another set he's trying to get
another second right there man
that was insane though man like we all
know like
the quarterback is going oh here it is
the shake oh damn Crosby
but we all know like the court he was
all the way out of Bounce right here so
you know like that was that was just too
much man and
you know um I think uh Jerry was he was
he was ejected after this hit like which
is which is rare because usually they
give you two personal fouls you're able
to get two personal fouls after this
when they just kicked him out of the
game after that one man because
he Justin Herbert is the second highest
player player in in the whole league man
you can't do that man like you can't do
that man like hey that was Tom Brady
they probably suspended him they
probably suspended them for a couple of
games after that but you know as a
defensive player like you can't we we
got to ease up on the guys on the
sideline man like the quarterback
he makes this thing go like if that was
a receiver I might have been different
if that was a running back ah that might
have been different but the quarterback
man that's that's just ridiculous to go
over and hit the guy like that man and
you know you just gotta you just gotta
know as a defensive player you you just
have to know this is pro sports you have
to know and I I think I think college
players they they know in college man
I'm not trying to pile on on Jerry you
know uh artillery right now but you just
gotta know man you know you can't we
can't do stuff like that on the sideline
man and you know to see the whole team
come to his defense man that's what
you're supposed to do did I tell you
what if somebody hit Josh I don't like
that I'm getting kicked out the game
because I'm not gonna let none of that
I'm not gonna let none of that fly man
so it's dope just it's dope that that
Herbert is okay and we knew he was okay
because he skipped away right after this
he he literally skipped away right after
the hit so he knew he was okay look at
him get up we knew he was okay man and
he just left all he lets the guys fight
his battles after that look at him
they're all on him now look they're
going crazy now so he knew his guys had
his back he didn't even check back to
see if they did man
he knew the guys you know had his back
and
that's how it goes man when you're a
franchise quarterback you know if we're
talking if we're talking Big Time games
we have to talk about CMC Christian
McCaffrey he had 20 carries 106 yards
four touchdowns in a 35 to 16 win over
the Cardinals like he he went crazy and
he's been going crazy we talked about
him earlier in the show and he is uh he
is one of the uh Front Runners to win
MVP
um he's the first running back he would
if he's able to win MVP which I'm hoping
Josh Ellen will but if he's able to win
MVP he'll be the first MVP since Adrian
Peterson to do it in 2012. and um
I think I think he I think he could do
it but hopefully I think I feel like
Josh Allen would beat him out because we
already said early in the show what that
would do for my team and my channel and
my team changes to win the Super Bowl
and with Josh Allen were the MVP so I'm
hoping Josh Allen will continue to have
the success that he has but if he
doesn't
sure why not I would love to see
Christian McCaffrey win MVP man like
Denver guy
um went to Valor High School Valor is my
son's name and I would love to see
Christian McCaffrey win it man and you
know since joining the 49ers 18 games
he's had 21 touchdowns
two thousand two hundred and twenty six
all-purpose yards and he's just going
insane
um
I've never played with a player of his
caliber on offense like that of course I
played with Peyton Manning and I play
with DT but a guy that that really takes
over the game at the running back
position like Christian McCaffrey no I I
really haven't man I've only been able
to Admire from a distance and I think um
I got it I would compare him to would
probably be uh
Alvin Kamara when Albert Camara was just
going absolutely crazy
um Reggie Bush when Reggie Bush was
Unstoppable you know I had to compare
him to those guys man like you know he
CMC is definitely in a lane of his own
though and it's exciting to watch it's
exciting to witness
um that was a crazy that was a crazy
slaying of games and before we move on
I'm gonna give you my top
teams in each conference starting with
the AFC
um I feel like the Buffalo Bills are
number one you know obviously we beat
the Miami Dolphins and the Miami
Dolphins is number one so I'll put the
Miami Dolphins I took Buffalo Bills at
one Miami Dolphins at two
um
well number three I would
got it you can't leave Kansas City
Chiefs out you can't leave can't see the
Chiefs out of nothing all right they got
Patrick Mahomes Travis Kelsey and they
got the swifties and Taylor Swift like
you can't leave those guys I had nothing
uh you can't leave those guys out
another and then um number four and
the
but AFC I would have to put
the Jets man because the Jets they're
playing good too even without
even without um Aaron Rodgers they still
have a really good team
um Zach uh Wilson is is really getting
better and better each and every game I
saw some plays in this Kansas City
Chiefs game that we that we saw
um he made some incredible throws he
made some incredible credible decisions
in that game and he looks like he's
really coming into his own and I think
you know having you know A-Rod in the
room and eight the whole show being
about A-Rod and A-Rod getting hurt the
third player of the Season it kind of
rejuvenated Zach Wilson I don't think he
I don't think he even expect to play
this whole season but it happened and
you got to be ready now and it shows you
a lot about Zach Wilson man that he's
he's ready to go he's ready to play
um now moving on to the NFC
obviously it's the 49ers in the in the
Eagles like and I think they're one and
one
I think the 49ers and the Eagles are one
and one you can't leave by the Cowboys
and um
you can't leave out
the Rams my former team too because they
look like they're both they look like
they're bubbling up something
they look like they're bubbling up
something and they look like they they
are are getting ready to make a run
um I think his name is uh Nuka the
receiver he's insane
um Matty Ice
um Matthew Stafford he's insane
and now um
you know that those are my teams man and
I like to go to the chat man and
and check out to see what would be your
your teams in the AFC in the NFC Von
Miller kill Von Miller's Killers says
Von is in my dream box this is some of
the answers from the DreamBox earlier we
have C Mourinho he said J Cole would be
in my dream box
is it and then we have Evan Whitmire he
says give me Von Miller Josh Allen
Tage Thompson and Sydney Crosby in the
Celeb box that's a good one
c c Jackson
says the whole Mafia getting kicked out
of the stadium if anyone came after Josh
Allen like that because we all fight
that is true like Bill's mom if you want
to play that HBK says
do you think this is the year for
double-digit sacks hypothetically if you
play next week or not I always feel like
it's double double digit second time for
me and I think I got enough games to do
it
um I think I can have enough enough
games to do what I need to do all I need
is two sacks to catch Derrick Thomas
though which
um is very very interesting for me and
I'm excited about that in a kind says
what is your all-time offense my
all-time offense would have to be
the best offense in NFL history and my
opinion would have to be the 2013 Denver
Broncos and nobody really talks about
that enough we have five players on that
offense with 10 touchdowns we have five
players on the offense with 10
touchdowns we have five players on that
offense with 10 touchdowns
it doesn't get talked about them enough
because
Peyton Manning went to his Super Bowl
and then lost to the Seattle Seahawks if
we if we were able to win that game then
it would be more talk about it two weeks
two years later we go to the Super Bowl
and we win it defensively Peyton Manning
still had a great game but it was a
defensive game and we were able to Win
It defensively and I feel like that just
puts the the buffer on that 2013 team
that that we had the 2013 Denver Broncos
offense was one of if not the best
offense of all time and that's that's
what I'm saying that obviously I was on
a team but that's what I'm saying it
but you know to end it you know next
week we got the Jags in London
this will be my first time playing in
London and I think uh it says what do
you think some of the challenges will be
playing abroad and what am I most
excited excited about
um
I think some of the most I think the
challenge would be obviously the time
difference
um they're six hours ahead of us
um we got to take a six hour flight to
get there
um
that that would probably be one of the
challenge that would probably be one of
the challenges I think playing just in a
new environment I've played in every NFL
stadium I played in every NFL stadium in
the NFL so I'm used to all of these
places I've played in all of these
stadiums multiple times so I think um
I'm used to that
and you know playing in a soccer stadium
would be a little bit different I don't
think it'd be different for me but I
just I'm just stating some of the
challenges for your typical NFL team and
I'm most excited uh about
um just just just playing in front of
the in front of the bridge man I'm I'm
excited to play in in front of the
English
um they have a really really great fans
man I've watched some of the soccer
teams and I've seen some of the the
London Games before man and they are
exciting man and they're sold out man
I'm excited to play there
um the Jags played on Sunday this last
week they're going to be there for two
weeks straight
um I feel like that I feel like that is
super cool man you get to spend two
weeks in London
um it might give them a little bit
Advantage because they're used you know
to playing they're playing at two
different stadiums they're playing in
Wembley and then they're playing in
Tottenham so they're getting a whole
London experience
um
I think I think
what the bills need to do to carry over
some momentum from Sunday's win over
um to London I think we just got to
continue to reset I think we just got to
continue to reset believe in our believe
in ourselves and just take it one day at
a time not one game at a time one day at
a time Wednesday's tomorrow we take
Wednesday as it comes then Thursday we
travel to London have all the respect
for the Jacksonville the Jaguars and
their team man and we just continue to
build on our team what we've done this
week so take it one day at a time travel
over there rest up and get ready for the
game
um I'll go to the chat one more time
oh we got war dog
um he answered number one bills two
49ers three eagles four Dolphins five
Chiefs six Cowboys I would think the
Chiefs are a little bit higher but
that's just my respect for Patrick
Holmes and their team and we got g-dog
right here he says uh who impressed you
the most on our team this year
I think Ed Oliver man he's definitely
he's he's definitely uh developing into
his own man and he's taking his spot
amongst top defensive players and no not
just offensive tackles he's taking his
spot amongst top defensive players in
the whole entire league and it's we're
starting to see it
um pre-prince says who do you think are
The Underdogs and both conferences are
um in AFC I would have to go to the
Denver Broncos because I know what type
of team they have
I know what type of team they have I
know what type of players they have I
know about that francho their franchise
man I think they're one of The Underdogs
um I think they'll be able to write the
ship
um and I'm excited I'm really excited to
see what the Denver Broncos do they're
playing the Chiefs this week so this
should be a big one this would be a big
one for them to show the NFL
um we got Pearl Pinchy doyers
says Vaughn shout out to my nephew JJ
it's his ninth birthday and he's one of
your biggest fans hey JJ happy birthday
my boy they got Jay Morales
and he said can't wait to put that fun
Jersey on let's go bills I would
appreciate that man
um I am super excited to be back
um like I said before
um I haven't played football since
Thanksgiving last year it's been a long
road from recovery and I'm happy to be
back I'm happy to leave all my pads on
I'm happy to be able to put my helmet on
and put my mouthpiece in I'm happy to
run out there and run around I'm sure
I'll get fatigued a little bit but I'm
happy to be fatigued I'm happy to be
back in the mix man I'm happy to be back
in gen pop with the prisoners man I'm
happy to be back with my guys man uh I'm
I'm I wanted to get out of solitary
confinement man and I'm happy to be back
in gen pop with my guys man with Micah
Hyde and and Josh child and Caillou are
happy to be around the guys man tomorrow
and all the guys man so
um
this has been episode two
of divine cast and I really appreciate
you guys for tuning in man and until
next time I see you guys later man thank
you I appreciate you that is a wrap
this is dope man
I appreciate you guys
[Music]